This is our simplified expression, 8a divided by the quantity a plus 5. We can
start factoring the numerator by removing a common factor of 8a from each term.
This leaves us with a second factor of a plus 4. This denominator is actually
identical to the last problem we looked at. The x has been replaced with a. So
we have the same factors, a plus 5 and a plus 4. We just have a instead of x. We
cancel the common factor of a plus four in the numerator and denominator,
leaving us with eight a divided by a plus five. Keep in mind these are both
positive ones, so we wouldn't need to change anything in terms of signs.
Sometimes our two factors might reduce to negative one. In that case we would
need to multiply our expression by a negative one. We would have a negative sign
in front.